un petit salon modeste du kremlin qui
sert à des rencontres informelles mais
les caméras sont bien là pour
immortaliser l'instant
marine le pen a enfin obtenu la
rencontre censée lui octroyer sa stature
internationale et elle a du mal à cacher
son émotion merci cette entrevue vous le
savez j'étais depuis longtemps et pour
que la france et la russie reprennent
des relations une candidate à l'élection
présidentielle qui s'engagent à oeuvrer
pour une levée des sanctions européennes
contre moscou vladimir poutine ne peut
qu'approuver même s'il se défend de
toute ingérence dans le scrutin que vous
disent est l'image de 2017 à la lumière
de 2022 c'est une image qu'elle est très
importante parce que la réalité c'est
que au fur et à mesure des années et au
fur et à mesure des choix qui ont été
faits par l'union européenne la russie
n'a eu de cesse que de s'éloigner en
fête de l'europe moi je pense qu'au
départ elle vous l'a dit marc poutine il
souhaitait que la russie ait des
relations avec l'europe et
accessoirement avec la france et à force
de l'en avoir éloigné il s'est tourné
vers la chine je pense que c'est une
très mauvaise une très mauvaise
il dès qu'on a eue là d'ailleurs parce
que il est beaucoup plus dangereux de
voir la russie avec la chine que la
russie en ayant des relations avec
l'europe mais là on est deux ans en fait
après les attentats du bataclan et moi
je vais voir vladimir poutine et je
défends l'idée que la russie qui peut
être par ailleurs un adversaire dans
certains endroits concurrents dans
d'autres on le voit bien en afrique
aujourd'hui mais incontestablement peut
être un allié dans la lutte contre le
fondamentalisme islamiste et je n'aurai
de cesse d'ailleurs que de pouvoir
rencontrer des dirigeants de pays pour
organiser
en fait sur des sujets qui sont des
sujets qu'on peut avoir en commun des
points de convergence voyez là je
rencontre vladimir poutine j'ai
rencontré il ya peu le président le
premier ministre polonais pour le coup
les deux peuvent pas s'entendre ils se
détestent cordialement leur pays sont
dans une guerre diplomatique majeur mais
parce que je pense que c'est le rôle de
la france le rôle de la france et de
cette puissance d'équilibré d'être
haïkus distance c'est d'être capable de
parler aux uns et aux autres et
accessoirement le moment venu de
rapprocher les positions des uns et des
autres mais dans cette visite est dans
cette poignée de main il y avait un peu
plus que des considérations stratégiques
ou de la realpolitik y avait foule avait
exprimé une forme d'admiration quand
vladimir poutine vous l'avez dit est-ce
qu'elle a ce qu elle affaiblie depuis
non mais l'administration non mais
pardon mais essayons d'avoir une vision
un petit peu cohérente la bonne humeur
poutine est un dirigeant politique qui a
réussi quand même à
arracher
de l'effondrement économique
de l'effondrement social un pays qui a
vécu des décennies
de
de bottes soviétique puis une décennie
de pillage ultralibéral voilà c'est ça
qui récupère et on peut avoir à son
égard énormément de réserve on peut s'en
méfier on peut le considérer brutal on
peut tout ce qu'on veut mais on ne peut
pas juger à traiter par le mépris le
dirigeant politique qu'il est parce que
il a réussi à faire de la russie à
nouveau un acteur de premier plan à
nouveau un pays qui tient la route sur
le plan économique donc moi j'essaye
d'être objective j'essaye de ne pas être
subjectif parce que quand on est
dirigeant politique on ne peut pas être
subjectif il ne faut pas être subjectif
il faut être
très comment dire lucide sur ce qu'il
est sur ce qu'est la russie mais il faut
aussi être capable de comprendre
pourquoi il agit comme ça qu'est ce
qu'il a derrière la tête qu'est ce qu'il
souhaite faire et qu'est ce qu'ils
cherchent à obtenir par la brutalité
qu'il exprime dans c'est sûr que ce qui
s'est passé là la guerre en ukraine est
inadmissible et insupportable
est à mon avis impardonnable mais je
pense surtout c'est une gigantesque
erreur de sa part
[Musique]